so it doesn't even matter if she's the
original in fact this organism is a
genius because now it has an alibi from
a survivor who's left the government
know and think that it's dead when in
reality it not only lives inside of
Lenna but her husband the film's primary
question is what is the shimmer the
film's haunting finale the two embraces
both of their irises fluctuate and
change color signaling the continuing
mutation and evolution caused by the
shimmer it now resides in Lena and Cain
who will live on to change the world
even further
however since Cain is a duplicate from
the shimmer the shimmer still remains in
him the glowing in their eyes is to show
us that the cells mutation process is
starting over again as it is once again
affecting Lena they're bound to have a
kid eventually who will be even more
shimmer like and continue on to evolve
in this world as it spreads its shimmer
Ness everywhere
[Music]
annihilation is a 2018 film written and
directed by Alex garland based on the
2014 novel of the same name by Jeff
Vandermeer it tells the story of Lena a
woman whose relationship with her
husband Kane has been brought to the
brink of collapse by dissatisfaction
infidelity absence and trauma and how
she confronts questions of self in the
face of difficulty depression and the
passage of time it is a movie about pain
and identity the plot of the film
revolves around an alien presence
referred to as the shimmer a mysterious
field slowly absorbing swampland in the
Florida Panhandle that serves as the
stage for a journey into the south when
a team of scientists including Lena
ventures into the shimmer with the goal
of finding its source the question at
the heart of annihilation is how do we
confront and deal with life-changing
events particularly tragedy and trauma
are we all fated to seek self
destruction by the coding and our very
cells to impulsively pursue our own
annihilation or is it possible to come
back from the brink of self eradication
I'm a simpleton over here and I just
want to talk about that aliens so I'm
going so I'm going to maybe end up
saying some unkind things and I just
want you to know that this really just
comes from the primal place deep inside
me that core of my being I have nothing
against any of the individuals whose
work I've shown but the specific
expressions mentioned just hurt me also
I I should speak first to the fans of
these videos hi fans welcome I don't
have anything against the people who
watch these kinds of videos because I
get it you come out of a movie that
impacted you whether it made you angry
or ecstatic it's a movie that has
energized you it has activated your
ideas and your emotions and you want
more of it maybe you need more to share
in your rage and achieve symbolic
closure or you need more because it has
ignited a spark and you want to keep
that spark alive either way you get home
and you rush to YouTube to see what
everyone else has
to say about it to share in the desired
energy I get it I really do because I do
this too I come out of a movie that
really engages me and immediately I want
to see what everyone else has to say
about it i watch the videos my peers may
have done
I read professional reviews I talked
about it on Twitter to get people to
engage hell I'd pull up a plot summary
just to keep the events fresh I get it
but these videos are bad but then
there's a lot of other people online who
are loving this movie and when you ask
them what it's about they just go oh I
don't know the reason I dislike these so
much is that they are often a form of
anti-intellectualism
operating on the attitude that ignorant
is purity that an understanding of
culture that rejects metaphor that
rejects the symbolic and clings to the
literal is more true it is part of the
process of denying art the capacity for
meaning now that's not to say that all
of these reject metaphor in its entirety
as an attitude anti-intellectualism is
not usually found in a pure form but in
ambivalence a pure and unalloyed dislike
of intellect or intellectuals is
uncommon it is rare to find someone who
will entirely reject the idea of
approaching film broadly from a thematic
or metaphorical point of view but all
too common to find people who will
lightly sneer at the actual attempts to
do so and suggest that it's overthinking
things
and by suggest I mean they will say it
in exactly those words this is a
consistent feature within modern film
criticism which taken on the whole is in
a distinct phase where the loudest
voices in film discussion are incurious
proudly ignorant and approach plot as a
problem to be unpacked and solved
reading so why do these videos about
this specific movie bother me so much
well it has to do with the movie itself
if you want to talk about theme metaphor
and meaning annihilation is a great
starting point
seriously this movie would be a
fantastic film to base an entry level
unit around not because it is simple or
simplistic but because it is dense and
where's most of its themes on its sleeve
it is in a word blunt between the
soundtrack and dialogue the film
straight-up tells you what it is about
on multiple occasions in a way it's to
bereavements my beautiful girl and the
person I once was if I don't reach the
lighthouse soon the person that started
this journey won't be the person that
ends it I want to be the one that ends
it you are okay are you
[Music]
I don't think so
are you Lena
the movie goes to great lengths to tell
the viewer that it is not a story about
literal events and trying to decode the
plot like a goddamn puzzle box isn't
just missing the point
it is willfully ignoring the story as it
is told to you this isn't always the
case but here for this movie
metaphorical is textual you know in
order to fill out a video with what
amounts to a little more than a linear
retelling of the plot requires the video
creators to ignore a substantial portion
of the text in order to get to the
ending or they can hypothesize on the
fate of the alien and miss literally the
entire point of the movie when in
reality it not only lives inside of
Lenna but her husband it now resides in
Lina and Kane who will live on to change
the world even further
however since Kane is a duplicate from
the shimmer the shimmer still remains in
him they're about to have a kid
eventually who will be even more shimmer
like oh my god if you were discussing
the ending of the movie without
discussing these scenes and how they
inform the meaning of the final shots
you aren't actually discussing the
ending of the movie you're writing
fanfiction this is how you get jarhead
sequels do you want jarhead sequels
because this is how you get jarhead
sequels and trains for 70 consecutive
days he gets to know every inch of his
m16a4 rifle then he earns the right to
be called a jarhead
[Music]
love being a Marine who rap at their
elemental level the themes and ideas
that annihilation grapples with aren't
exactly new now I'm not a huge fan of
the hero with a thousand faces I think
it tries too hard to flatten culture and
make an interesting observation about
narrative patterns into a universal
truth but it is fair to say that
annihilation is a journey in a very
classical sense and borrows from the
broadest strokes there is a call to
adventure a wise and sage a fellowship
and the crossing of a very literal
threshold and indeed change is central
to Campbell's monomyth the hero returns
home triumphant but in some way no
longer belongs because they have changed
home has changed or both and the new is
incompatible with the old hero's return
not as pig farmers but as Kings Luke
can't go back to the farm because the
farm has been destroyed and he's being
swept up in a rebellion the vault
dweller can't return to the vault
because their time in the wasteland has
filled them with too many radical ideas
Frodo must go into the West because he
no longer belongs in middle-earth you've
got a lot of loss of innocence a lot of
war and a lot of loss of innocence in
war so yeah the idea that the very act
of going on a journey changes you isn't
new annihilation however rejects the
prelapsarian ideal Lena doesn't start
the movie innocent there isn't a state
of grace to fall from and she doesn't
return home as Campbell's warrior lover
Emperor Redeemer or Saint indeed
annihilation asks a far more challenging
question what if you returned home and
you're different but you're still just
you at the end of her tribulations Lina
has been changed has been altered but is
still Lina indeed counter to Campbell's
hero it is the very fact that home has
changed an equal portion to herself that
enables Lina to return in the first
place
before we go on this is a good moment to
talk about the point of ambiguous
endings and narrative ambiguity in
general the purpose of ambiguity is to
frustrate the audience to deny a clean
sense of diegetic closure and thusly
force engagement with the metaphorical
most ambiguous endings make perfect
sense if you read them somatic lis and
nine times out of ten the diegetic
answer is obvious once you approach the
ending from this direction if you
approach the final shots of annihilation
thematically the meaning of this moment
is very obvious but if you resist a
thematic reading then you're going to
get caught up in weird nonsense circles
asking if the shimmer is an alien
terraforming device as though the next
movie annihilation to is going to be a
bunch of rainbow aliens coming down in
spaceships getting into gunfights with
aaron eckhart okay let's be honest
Gerard Butler on this journey the fate
of the five women reflects a variety of
possible outcomes in the face of
catastrophe and pain each an extension
of their trauma cassie is the victim of
fate killed through no fault of her own
when a bear drags her off into the night
and she is unwillingly consumed into the
catastrophe this is an echo of Cassie's
own words from earlier the person she
used to be was destroyed by the loss of
her daughter to leukemia itself an event
that she could neither prevent nor
escape at the end of the day we are all
a roll of the dice away from disaster
Anja the addict is likewise consumed but
where Cassie was the unfortunate victim
of bad luck Anja provokes her fate
allowing her rage and paranoia to
overcome her before fully
self-destructing at the hands of an
outside force Josie in contrast gives in
peacefully embracing her own Oblivion
and simply vanishing into the plantlife
content with never knowing the things
she doesn't know she observes that
venturous wants to face the shimmer and
Lena wants to fight it but she wants
neither of those things she is willing
to trade closure for her money in her
final moments she
guards her long-sleeve shirt for a tank
top wearing her scars honestly at peace
with revealing her secret self to Lina
as she first absorbs greenery into
herself before being absorbed seamlessly
into the greenery
Josie isn't just metaphorically in
harmony with the shimmer which is to say
her damage she becomes one with the
shimmer Ventress is dying of cancer a
woman at war with her own body and at
war with the changes that confronting
mortality impose on who she is
when Lina catches up to her at the
Lighthouse at the epicenter the shimmer
like the cancer is already inside her
and here in the holy of holies at last
Ventris and Lina confront the thing only
to discover that pain is ultimately an
unknowable indescribable thing a
consuming force that refract everything
it touches and turns us into dark
reflections of ourselves we're left
unchecked it becomes the singular thing
consuming everything until even the
component parts are no longer
recognizable bodies and our minds will
be fragmented into their smallest parts
until no one part remain Ventress is
destroyed from within by her own cells
betraying and consuming her finally in
Lena's confrontation with the being she
first tries to run but is unable to
escape and is nearly suffocated it is
not until she accepts that the being
that the pain and trauma is a part of
her a reflection of her that she is able
to confront it directly and destroy it
allowing her to escape and reunite with
Kain the horror of annihilation is
existential and rooted firmly in the
ordinary it is film confronting the
gradual ways that we are changed by the
things and people around us the ways
that we slowly drift from one state into
another the terror of waking up one day
to realize that we've become someone
else someone we don't recognize it is
about life-changing events both the big
and dramatic and the slower subtler kind
the pain of losing a child and also the
relationship that gradually slides into
alienation references to cancer
are particularly important in the film
Lena teaches pre-med students about the
biology of cancer
Cassie's daughter died of leukemia and
Ventress has some unspecified but
terminal cancer the opening monologue
ruminates on the idea of cancer as
immortal cells that have had their
self-destruct code turned off healthy
productive cells die while toxic deadly
cells live forever consuming devouring
absorbing and corrupting this extends
into the metaphor as an irony why is it
that everything we live for dies while
our pain gets to be immortal the shimmer
itself is a stand-in for trauma
depression terminal disease addiction
alienation grief and every other moment
in our lives that leaves us unmoored
from ourselves this absorption is
realized literally with characters
physically absorbing elements of each
other as the film progresses no better
is this encapsulated than in the
Ouroboros tattoo Anya has a tattoo of an
Ouroboros on her left forearm a detail
that's present from the beginning of the
film but difficult to catch until later
as the film gradually calls attention to
it the key turning point comes when the
expedition reaches the former
headquarters of the southern reach in
one of the film's few overtly horrifying
scenes the women come across a data card
left behind by the previous expedition
on the card is a video file showing the
team flying one of their own a soldier
with an Ouroboros tattoo just like
Anya's revealing his intestines writhing
like coil of snakes
the final remains of this soldier are
then found encased in lichen and mold
growing into the wall of the pool Anya
and the soldier are of the same that is
the meaning or at least a meaning of the
shared tattoo in the soldier she sees
herself she realizes this fear
references it explicitly when she later
ties up the surviving members of the
team if I let you go and you tied me to
a chair and got me open
I kind of move like my finger mm-hmm her
fear is that she has become like and as
the soldier on the wall but really she
already was then in Lena's darkest
moment her absolute nadir following the
deaths of Cassy and Anja Ventress
departure and Josie's transformation
when she is the most alone the tattoo
appears on her arm Lena has absorbed
something of Anja something that she
will carry for the rest of her life this
is a good place perhaps to postulate on
whether the soldier already had the
tattoo before entering the shimmer or if
it is in some way a manifestation of the
shimmer and the answer is that it
doesn't matter because no matter what
the dietetic answer may be the symbol
has taken on meaning through its
association with each of the characters
where it came from is irrelevant next to
what it indicates the impact individuals
have on one another how we become
impressed into each other and entwined
the ways that we see ourselves our
faiths in complete strangers a cycle of
exchange without beginning or end life
changes us in unpredictable ways we
absorb our environments and the people
around us and as horrifying as that
sounds it's not always sometimes and
this is the note that anihilation
chooses to go out on recognizing that
there is an existential horror to the
nature of intimate relationships that
opening ourselves to others allowing
them in brings with it an annihilation
of our singular self we merge we reshape
we combine and replicate and mirror and
on a level that is terrifying to be with
someone is to sacrifice something of who
you are but it's also beautiful in the
final moments Lena and Kain confront the
fact that they are no longer the people
they used to be they have both changed
dramatically radically since their
relationship began their slow drift
apart Lena's infidelity Cain's out
and his nearly fatal illness have
compounded and altered both of them down
to the core of their very being but even
if they are no longer the Lina and Kane
they used to be they are still a Lina
and a Kane and their shared experience
the way they have absorbed one another
into their identities has made them into
the same they are still one person and
two alone yeah but did the aliens [ __ ]
[Music]